[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le sky
échos le magazine qui vous racontent la
vie des acteurs économiques du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
et pour cette édition nous sommes au
parc floral à paris pour l'édition 2022
tech'innove tech'innove c'est le rendez
vous des acteurs de l'innovation et
encore une fois comme chaque année saint
quentin en yvelines est bien représentée
avec ces grands groupes comme thales
airbus ou encore le elle est nommé aussi
avec ces startups comme idact au rdi
manager ou encore à ce vestige c'est ce
que vous allez découvrir dans ce 35e
numéro du ska hip hop
[Musique]
convention d'affaires spécialisé dans
l'innovation technique ce sont de
nombreux rendez vous entre des start up
des pme des grands groupes ou encore des
investisseurs ils recherchent tous des
opportunités de business et pour en
parler nous sommes avec le président de
tech'innove et directeur régional
ile-de-france d'airbus développement
laurent legendre bonjour bonjour
alors commence pas cette édition 2022 de
techno et bien écoutez c'est un bonheur
de retrouver un salon en présentiel en
plus sans les masques et surtout avec un
grand succès mille six cents personnes
présentes je vais avoir le chiffre du
nombre de rendez vous mais on est
quelque part entre quinze et vingt mille
donc c'est assez énorme ça a très bien
fonctionné ça montre qu' il y avait une
attente l'an dernier on avait fait une
édition distant ciel qui avait permis de
maintenir le fil mais il fallait
retrouver les contacts en réel il n'y a
rien de tel pour
identifier des projets définir de
nouveaux projets entre certains pys
novembre qui a sorti une brique et un
donneur d'ordre qui va pouvoir lui
confier des travaux et
plus si affinités si la preuve de
concept fonctionne on a déjà des retours
de cas qui ont fonctionné et qui ont
donné lieu à des développements de
produits qui sont maintenant
commercialiser ses nombreux participants
c'est le signe de la reprise économique
ça y est elle est bien présente oui
elle est présente locaux vides est
derrière nous pareil à une nouvelle
crise qui est arrivé de l'est
qui apporte effectivement quelques
contraintes nouvelles et tout ça en fait
est un stimulant pour l'innovation les
thèmes qui ont été choisis pour tech
innove cette année
sur un nombre de cinq ont à cinq
villages thématiques on a regroupé et ce
sont tous des thèmes qui sont issus de
ce qui est ressorti du co lead ce sont
des réflexions alors il ya la medtech
évidemment il fallait sortir un vaccin
donc mais la medtech c'est beaucoup de
technologies qui vont permettre de
répondre à d'autres problèmes de crise
quête sanitaire qui peuvent revenir
c'est un sujet important et puis toutes
ces réflexions qui sont arrivés avec le
bolide avec cette crise économique sur
des nouveaux sujets la transition
énergétique le numérique
alors la défense on n'avait pas on
n'avait pas anticipé d'ukraine quand on
a fait le village défense mais il est
bien présent ici
et tech'innove a toujours été orientées
sur des sujets qui sont les grands
sujets sociétaux du moment et qui
peuvent donner lieu à des développements
de nouvelles filières industrielles et
l'industrie est vraiment le sujet qui
est en train de monter
sur les yvelines et à saint quentin
c'est un sujet fort on a le département
le plus industriels de toute l'île de
france
il ya vraiment un intérêt à relancer des
filières qui ont été impactés si je
prends les deux premières filières
dehimi l'aéronautique et l'automobile on
a perdu 25% du chiffre d'affaires avec
le bolide ça revient mais ça a été un
choc et donc il faut relancer ça mais le
relancer différemment et pour le
relancer plus efficacement être meilleur
que ses concurrents il n'y a qu'une
solution c'est innover parle on vous
l'avait évoqué de l'invasion de
l'ukraine par la russie qui renvoie des
nouveaux enjeux autour de la
cybersécurité de la défense de
l'indépendance énergétique avec en toile
de fond finalement un sujet c'est la
souveraineté européenne oui alors on est
en train de se rendre compte que les
vieux sujet
de la défense là reviennent au premier
plan sur
sur des produits de défense classique
comment redonner des anneaux armée plus
de capacités et sur le village défense
et sécurité on a des start-up président
sur la cybersécurité également puisque
là on a vu se multiplier ces dernières
semaines des attaques
probablement caisse très
très à l'est de langue
et on a des start up qui glisse mais
cette attaque là nous on aurait pu
l'empêcher on a la techno pour le faire
donc c'est très intéressant et on a
essayé de pousser avec les chambres de
commerce ces entreprises à se développer
plus vite pour que leurs solutions
soient opérationnels et commercialisé
très vite parce qu'on en a un besoin
immédiat
merci laurent legendre si nicolas je
rappelle que vous êtes de président de
tech'innove donc l'événement sur lequel
nous nous trouvons et vous est aussi
directeur régional ile-de-france
d'airbus développement et je vous
propose maintenant d'ailleurs d'aller
rencontrer les dirigeants saint
quentinois qui sont présents sur cet
événement
[Musique]
on est en plein dans le numérique est
vraiment là l'idée c'est d'aider les
entreprises à leur transition numérique
alors admis ticket spécialisée dans les
solutions d'hébergement l'infogérance et
l'administration systèmes sous linux
alors que coton riz cloud on est
vraiment spécialisés dans une solution
pour mettre à disposition des
entreprises des logiciels open source et
aider les entreprises françaises à
rapatrier leurs données en france
c'était lui entoure est un site
d'une quarantaine de collaborateurs
ingénieurs jeunes docteurs experts
spécialisés dans l'informatique
scientifique et la modélisation multi
physiques dans tout le domaine
principalement le spatial la défense
lorraine gaz l'industrie et le nucléaire
et agri manager c'est une plateforme de
management de l'innovation à destination
des entreprises innovantes ont développé
un journal collaboratif de projet pour
les entreprises qu'elles puissent
culture et capitaliser et gérer les
informations techniques pertinentes
tech'innove nous permet vraiment de nous
mettre en avant fin nous permet d'avoir
de la visibilité dans notre domaine et
de montrer aussi notre hyper expertise
dans le domaine des raisons de
visibilité
sachant que nous sommes très fortement
focalisée sur l'innovation les phases
amont
des projets de r&d tech'innove on est
dans l'innovation et dans notre élément
en fait et puis ça nous permet de
rencontrer à la plupart de nos futurs
clients de nos poster de le présenter
l'application et puis de recueillir
aussi pas mal de feedback pour continuer
à développer notre produit
[Musique]
c'est une start-up incubés hausse qui
occupe depuis 2010 8 6 kg au développent
cette cabine de relaxation après un tour
de france et une levée de fonds en 2019
cette start up a été frappé de plein
fouet par la crise sanitaire pour en
parler nous sommes avec son fondateur
hervé mation bonjour bonjour merci
nicolas nous accueillir
on a passé deux ans extrêmement
difficile avec cette crise sanitaire on
a essayé de jouer notre rôle à travers
la crise puisque on a mis nos cabines à
disposition des soignants et ça c était
par contre une vraie expérience
maintenant je vous cache pas qu'on est
heureux d'être là aujourd'hui parce que
parce que financièrement ça a été très
difficile avec eux on nous a
indirectement interdit de travailler
donc pour une start up c'était compliqué
j'étais obligé de reprendre un travail
voilà donc c'est d'autant plus difficile
c'est qu'il faut travailler dans
l'entreprise plus essayer de de relever
cette start-up parce qu'on peut pas
abandonner c'est un projet qui est
vraiment qui est tellement d'impact et
qui marche tellement bien que l'on peut
pas s'arrêter là vous êtes un
entrepreneur un des entrepreneurs
français qui avait été face finalement
alors comme beaucoup malheureusement
mais il faut savoir que 80 % des
startups françaises ont été impactés par
par la crise
malheureusement il ya encore aujourd'hui
beaucoup de startups qui sont en train
de déposer le bilan gd propres collègues
qui ont investi cinq ans de leur vie
parfois deux cent mille euros de leur
poche et qui sont en train de tout
perdre donc c'est une vraie difficulté
vous êtes présent aujourd'hui au tech
innove c'est la relance c'est la reprise
d'activité ça y est alors la reprise je
dirais pas que c'est la reprise mais en
tout cas déjà ça nous fait du bien de
repartir dans ce projet
je suis presque ému de vous dire ça mais
oui
ç'a failli s'arrêter disons oui
c'était extrêmement difficile et savez
c'est des gens comprennent pas en fait
les start up il pense que une start up
c'est des gens à qui bricolent dans leur
jardin ce qui est pas faux à la base
très souvent ce sont des ingénieurs sont
des férus de technologie mais il oublie
une chose c'est que ce sont avant tout
aussi des investisseurs on met beaucoup
de temps mais on a aussi beaucoup
d'argent mois ses trente ans de ma vie
c'est 30 ans d'économies de ma vie de de
carrière que j'ai mis là-dedans
financièrement j'ai un pacte et des gens
aussi j'ai des investisseurs personnelle
des gens qui ont mis de l'argent vous
n'avez pas le droit en fait de les
décevoir et donc oui oui c'est très très
difficile il va ça y est vous voyez
disons le bout du tunnel ou pas tout va
dépendre de ce qui va se passer derrière
ce qu'on va être confiné ou pas mais oui
on espère et en tout cas les rendez-vous
qu'on ait aujourd'hui j'ai pas arrêté
depuis aujourd'hui la cabine était plein
donc donc oui on sent qu'un intérêt il
ya des investisseurs qui sont venus on
amène les canadiens qui sont venus nous
voir donc donc voilà je pense qu'il ya
un vrai intérêt j'espère que ça va nous
relancer un petit peu quoi merci r b
nation merci beaucoup à vous rappelle
fondateur de 6 kg au la cabine de
relaxation incubés au ski cube
[Musique]
c'est l'une des start up sélectionnées
par saint quentin en yvelines pour
participer à tech'innove iddac taux est
une entreprise spécialisée dans la
cybersécurité
fondé il ya deux ans cette start up est
déjà en forte croissance les détails
avec son fondateur has had made dans ma
vie d'entrepreneur
[Musique]
il est au c comme identité acto dans le
langage espéranto veut dire le contrat
de l'identité
[Musique]
je suis à san bad directeur général de
la société idact aux îles d'actos est
une société qui a été créée en 2019
juste avant la période de la crise
sanitaire et qui est spécialisée dans le
domaine de la gestion des identités et
des accès on va dire les identifications
des personnes qui souhaitent utiliser
des services en ligne c'est une société
qui compte aujourd'hui trente personnes
et qui embauche énormément dans le
domaine de la cybersécurité alors le
saut content d'être dans un bassin de la
cybersécurité à saint quentin en
yvelines et c'est ce qui nous permet
aujourd'hui d'attirer des compétences de
toute la france
[Musique]
nous sommes spécialisés dans un domaine
de la cybersécurité qui est un peu
particulier puisqu'il s'agit
d'identifier les gens et de protéger d
usurpation d'identité sur l'usagé des
services en ligne nos solutions
permettent tout en assurant la sécurité
pour les utilisateurs et les
fournisseurs de services de mettre en
relation utilisateurs fournisseurs de
services et souvent c'est le rôle de
l'état c'est pour ça que nous
intervenions beaucoup dans le cadre de
projets étatiques et souverain
dès 2020 nous avons déjà réalisé un
chiffre d'affaires supérieur à 1 million
et puis nous avons doublé notre chiffre
d'affaires de nous sommes à un rythme de
croissance de 100% ces perspectives sont
d'emmener notre technologie française en
dehors des frontières et donc nous
souhaitons aujourd'hui ouvrir énormément
de présence dans les pays européens mais
aussi sur le continent africain où la
demande actuellement est très forte
c'est la fin du sky eco tech innove 2022
merci d'avoir suivi cette émission vous
pouvez la revoir en rifle et sur notre
site internet ou sur l'application
mobile à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]